yeah hello welcome to this broadcast
welcome to this monday evening in Europa
Monday afternoon in the US yeah he
scores at least as always it's afternoon
at least in the US yeah okay i'm looking
forward to play a couple of blitz games
here yeah it was close that we actually
could have had a playoff today for the
London chess classic but we didn't so
it's basically just just me on here on
the ICC okay I'm going to kick off with
five minute games should I play a three
minute game to warm up yeah okay playing
panopticon okie dokie I'm going 9003 my
ears on stuff um okay you have to say
that I didn't play any blitz last week I
really didn't get to do it had too many
other things on my plate so this is
essentially yeah connecting right from
last week session connecting continuing
is the right word okay he played a kind
of double of here I care to hear quite a
solid um way of playing for Black Sea
five mmm yeah
hmm looks very ok Mary okay for him yeah
hello to all of you in the chat down who
do we have made grinder with Solano my
Ponzi people chorus t cyborg then easel
card lublin s Lublin NASA's 32 and
bioshock writer as its stolid yeah it
has okay someone says it's frozen on the
screen yeah maybe you have to refresh
sometimes twitches a bit strange okay so
he got this and hmm ok I go d5 going to
get that space ok so it's attacking this
part I think I will have to go look see
one here night only five is not
necessarily a great piece so we'll see
what to make out of this yes b5
sometimes but not right away I will just
take it hmm i think bishop age six looks
normal here that Bishop looks like is
best piece and the scoring system of the
london chester classic classic is just
complete bogus i didn't understand
anything at all why mdl now should be in
third place as kind of weird flaming
plate the the playoff against or having
played this far so called final against
cause it's just completely ridiculous
but well yeah have no idea what to tell
you it just feels entirely bonkers so
i'm just going whoo p1 here I also could
have played before that actually wasn't
interesting move
okay so be three ya feel goose i was Kia
yeah best wishes back to keel keel azam
city in the northern parts of Germany
probably not so well known if you are in
the US or and now in in the UK or
something okay I go route be one that
actually threatens look takes be a
twinning that night the night is in a
bad way there ok so now I think you see
threatening look before yeah almost I
think I'll have a look there yeah so um
there are questions a friend told
someone says that a friend told him that
the Budapest gambit line with a 495 f4
is forced win now that's nonsense it's
not that great actually and the urban
county gambled with for III instead of
93 this is actually a decent line it's
just not very it's not very necessary to
play there are many good alternatives
I've made a video on how to get an
advantage against the Albans and I think
this is pretty pretty young pretty good
yeah hello to go fix mix hello to London
I remember you and yeah I've played
video games as a kid and even a couple
of years ago I still do play the
occasional Skyrim or stuff like that I
started a game of scary actually just a
couple of days ago
I'm not sure if John Bartholomew will
get the GM title it's mostly a question
of how much you wanted he definitely I
can do it it's not a it's not that the
issue but I know from my own experience
as a teacher that you have for many
things to do if you if you mostly teach
chess and it's not so not so easy to to
get them to get the discipline for your
own work I'm also of course thinking
about it if I should should shoot for a
GM title but I would really have to work
a lot and and hard because I simply
don't have the level I mean at the
moment I think I could maybe get there
but it is a matter of of lots of work
and not not just yeah playing one
tournament and then you have it or so i
don't think i played this too well
actually i feel like my pieces i kind of
kind of stuck maybe i should regroup
there looking for was a stupid idea
threatening now to move the bishop yes I
had a Commodore Reyes but I also had to
add various various stuff had also Atari
console and all kinds of stuff
okay bishop is six just or you can just
cover it I didn't really pay attention
to that possibility hmm
I never had an Amiga I actually had an
atari st at one point st at some point
one reason was that it had chessbase it
was the first computer that had
chessbase only later they switch to pc
yeah that wasn't super convincing what I
did here so I wonder how to do at him
but check him first or is that i'll just
take is how do i get it as king may be
here and ruchi aid
Queen d8 mate as my idea as usual I'm
not the most subtle person let's shoot
for rue k7 now and Quincy ate meat so I
can take a six now or check him again
probably check him again yeah chessbase
was originally on atari st and they they
later switch to to pc one down to 30
something seconds this is actually not
so easy
I don't see how i made him actually huh
what is this connection my ping is ok I
you forfeit on time okay um okay um any
questions missed there's a question by
Corus t how do you know when to look for
tactics in the game so you can save time
but still be aware it's difficult it's
difficult to spot sometimes if you have
tactics there or not only yesterday I
played a tournament game where I was
immensely lucky immensely lucky I played
really badly and and miss stuff left and
right I'm going to do a video on that
for sure on my channel look look forward
to that it will be interesting and I
also of course I will do a video on the
on the end of the London chess classic
but I couldn't really do it yet had no
time whatsoever ok I'm playing Lord Jim
this is International Master Jia one I
cannot pronounce that Bosch and yeah
he's actually the guy being responsible
for my team and Germany playing in the
2nd bundesliga because he was yeah he
made a huge blunder in the league game
against us and instead of um yeah
drawing a particular game he lost it and
this is how we promote it to the second
German league yeah do a commentary with
with Oleg us know what that won't happen
I really only I only play as many games
against him as I absolutely have to ok
he got f5 and I never wanted to go age 3
because it held wrong maybe I should
have should have played it ok I think I
have to take problem
is it possible to make a living based
around chess um well do I look dead to
you I don't think I looked at I'm life
that it works it works um it's just that
you you should be too um let's say how
do you call it you shouldn't be too
ambitious what you can achieve
financially if you are kind of okay with
being being modest it's it's totally
okay and you cannot really do it by and
by playing of course it's teaching
writing producing other content like
videos and stuff like that um I think
the best game of the event was cards and
I camera pretty clearly okay he's going
there I can take only five for capture
d6 check almost his Bishop e6 close if i
take that twice I can't do that this is
not bad I actually wonder what is what
is up to him if I just take a six yeah i
think the cards in the camera game was
the was the most interesting game it is
also a little bit special for me because
i had the opportunity to do live
commentary on the game together with
them grandmaster Alexei Emelin ski here
on the on them ICC and that was a very
interesting experience because that end
game yeah the end game was very
interesting very instructive and it's
just that llamo is so far better in the
end came then I am that I could really
learn a ton about this type of position
um
the favorite player in the grand chest
to her and I cannot tell really I don't
really have so much of a favor to
favorite player yeah what is what is Sir
mr. Jim doing now and I just snatched
that pawn and I don't see a compensation
yeah the Giri mvl game in the rapid was
indeed interesting as someone pointed
out it was was good stuff by Gary okay
so what about this special form
oh I'm know I'm I was close to
blundering made into it would have been
cool hmm so what to do him hmm that was
an interesting move here that that thing
it takes only three I can take with the
Queen that's not a big deal maybe I just
move my bishop back yeah let's just do
that if I take a three um Queen takes
Bishop takes rook t1 should be good for
white yeah it was a bit of a pest with
the puddin even though um they were
actually quite a number of interesting
games with it it wasn't all boring every
game there were a couple of interesting
games it it wasn't that bad actually I
mean I kept complaining during the
broadcasts about it but it wasn't it
wasn't so terrible um okay
Siddiq's there hmm so some kind of some
kind of tactic here that I don't see I
feel that what he does here should not
work but cannot tell you why okay let's
just go back yeah why his openings are
not that great that's true and he also
has pretty serious deficits and
strategic chess still so for example if
it would play World Championship match
let's say I mean you will have to be
realistic he would be losing like like
completely without any kind of chance I
mean he would just be killed by any of
the top 10 players they would just
figure that out on their own how tricky
has endgame and strategic knowledge
a--'s or sketchy it is swidler already
showed that very clearly in the world
cup I think one of the best approaches
to learning an opening is to pick the
experts of the opening and study what
they do study the whole game so let you
get an idea about the middle games that
is really my standard advise someone
already said that I've I've been on
record with that advice but it is
typical standard advice that basically
of the cultural coaches some give okay
um does he have rook e8 now probably not
as level b1 okay this one
yeah I am not sure about this if I can
win with that pawn there but I hope I
can so how do i do it um how do i get
about this may be here taking the t6
pawn can I get to my if he goes here I
can go here for queen bee aid you cannot
take the pawn now I have to be quick i
just saw that i'm down on time a lot
actually so I can check him but how do i
how do i get get his queen away their
Bishop e3 bishop CA that's my idea ok I
can go back now but I can also do this
it cannot be bad getting the bishop into
the game he cannot check me anyway ok I
can do this in this ok it's mostly
trying for the time-based win if I check
here I can do this though
if he moves back I can go here because
I'm promoting if he takes and this is
the wind now even with 10 seconds
yeah I was a lot quicker than him so I'm
sorry I didn't pay any attention to the
chat the completes is c3 Sicilian by
especially curve is it good sketchy it's
a bit weird it's um it's it's a bit
weird because especially Cobb is
entirely and systematic about things you
get lots of interesting advice I mean
the guy knows his receipt c3 stuff but
it's kind of unorganized its kind of
unorganized um yeah opening DVDs /
Andrew Martin hmm i'll pass on those now
there are a couple of good ones but he
also has made a couple that were kind of
yeah you know it doesn't feel like he
invested as much time as you as you
probably should have done okay and
playing my way from Norway we know that
i played him a couple couple of times so
I'm going a 3 here usually I've got
black so it's kind of an uncommon that I
have white against him
a good line against the c3 Sicilian um
there is a couple of interesting lines
you have to also be aware that if you it
depends on what you play on move to
against 90 of three what you should
choose but there are some interesting
lines that you can go for with e 69 c6
and d6 that I like c3 for example efore
c5c 39 f6e 595 93 e 6 d 4 cd for cd4 d6
that is a good line with e 66 and the
knight on d5 that is a very very decent
line ok he went with his Knight to e5
yeah White has some interesting choices
some interesting options here even if or
as a move Knight g4 is the problem or
the possible problem that same ok I
think I'll allow that the line given by
the final zoosk one is is also
interesting to see 3 g6 the especially
cough is a really weird guy he also
believes that against one year for only
five and c5 are playable openings e6 is
is losing and and all kinds of stuff the
caro-kann is not playable and another
thing it's kind of weird but it's it's
still kind of interesting because he has
he has ideas it's not like he's just
talking nonsense all the time ok
interesting year said after Queenie to
his got 93 and I'm getting killed my
idea here was to play Queen here
and then drive him all the way back and
get all those Tempe on the Queen
the numbers in parentheses near the
ratings is the porn count so I'm a porn
down yeah especially cough believes that
the advanced range is basically refuting
refuting the French defense
yeah it takes a while now my idea is to
play okay that that seems that seems
crazy to be honest wow it seems that he
opts for he wants to go for some creepy
form
okay okay if I could
okay I'm going to kick the Queen away
super tough position here early on my
way is a very dangerous player it's a
very tactical very creative you have to
be absolutely on your game I probably
think that the French defense can be
refuted with many many lines it's a bit
strange mr. specially cough
I mean what I actually agree with is
that if I've and c5 are probably the
best moves that I probably would agree
with but you cannot say that the French
is an incorrect opening on or the
caro-kann or something like that that
just is just entirely stupid ok anyway
this is a very tough position yeah I
think I have to go out of this but where
do I go see going queen bee six again I
don't know
my development is not good that's
probably leading to some crazy time
scrambles I think there are a couple of
lines against the French that would
probably be a kind of slightly better
for wide but it is difficult of course
it's a complex opening it's not easy at
all to play so I cover f2 with that
rocky movie but I think it's a good move
yeah my development he is not good I am
certainly not going to argue against
that it sort of just happened I wasn't
actively a going after this kind of
position this should be his friend
wow that looks bad I just hope I survive
the next couple of moves
you
I cannot even castle in the next couple
of moves that's bad
I Scott bishop is sick so he just took
it
you
just stepping out of the idea three
chick Wow
the worst thing is I cannot castle
otherwise it might still be kind of
playable
Oh what did you go to h4 actually
I one time huh with 00 01 oh my god ah
that was so uh stuff I was tough okay so
let's go for the next one who Maradona
Maradona okay so let's see what we can
do here we can go for that one I always
have this against him and you place
lines that I like for black but I
sometimes still screw up yeah it's a
similar Donna from the blitz games yeah
this is you see I played against me
earlier and I think that this line is
just bad for white it's very difficult
to even get a play of a position method
wow that's it sorry that guy that's not
not going to work unless I'm doing
something stupid of course i can always
screw it up White has no development
here no development that's even worse
than the game I had the one before I was
white
yeah that's that's not good that's not
good and it's all in my book yeah the
only thing is I really have to remember
stuff and I cannot even look it up yeah
got that green screen behind me ah yeah
their position is indeed very bad for
white but you can still do stupid stuff
with white I would black I've done my
fair share of stupid stuff this is the
suit should be good take screen edge
form gets it back
okay let's think think about this for a
moment i think i'll just take here and
take on c6 it's the classical dutch a
bed opening no it's not terribly bad
it's just kind of not for everybody it's
you have to I mean this is something
that is um where black is balancing on
the edge let's say strategically but you
often get interesting counter chances I
mean Simon Williams is known for playing
it he has written books about it and he
has beaten with the opening that many
strong players who couldn't really get
something much and I mean he played this
like in situations where the other guys
could prepare he won against Gelfond
voyeur Shaq all kinds of young players
of absolute top class and I just great
that he managed that he managed to to
get this kind of results and so it
cannot be terribly bad it's just it's
just a very special kind of position
that I for instance I couldn't play that
the most aggressive defense to 184 I
don't know the the some Sicilian line
probably if he won't sound there are
probably a couple of a couple of unsound
one's the best gambit that's not the
Queens gambit yeah there's the Marshall
gambit yeah but is lehman against the r
is also not that bad a couple of decent
ones i also think i'm not quite sure the
banco gambit they have those recent
ideas that seem kind of interesting so
one even about the banco you cannot be
sure
so Bishop b4 Bishop d2 was just about
her willing
hmm I can play this Bishop t to Bishop t
a bit Bishop b4 Bishop t2 takes takes
rook takes e4 pawn takes yeah it's not
bad but I was thinking I would have more
Bishop g4 wins on the spot thanks for
telling me too late but I think this is
also not bad you can also play a 45 as
black pretty aggressively there are many
interesting lines that you can that you
can go for it doesn't need to be the
Berlin ending all the time going for
rupee for here
now I definitely didn't get the best of
the maximum out of it it's pretty ups I
shouldn't blunder Knight f6 yeah yeah
the Italian game you can of course play
the Italian game the that slowish lines
but there are really not promising white
anything yeah it's bitter awful but i
think i have to take the draw here I'm
ahead on the clock but I don't see how I
can do anything here bishop CA it I can
go back to ca it ok then I can do
without compromising my position too
much
yeah the Italian game that slowish
Italian game lines they they sometimes
are really stale kind of not happening
much
might go see five-year know is that on
doesn't help him a lot it's it's still a
very Jewish position
I am still kind of annoyed that I didn't
really didn't punish his terrible
opening to the fullest
it's got kinky five should have thought
about that ok I think I just go over
here and make mega draw here I can offer
him a draw here if he likes
and I offered the draw twice I'm not
going to operate a third time I can also
win on time of course would like a style
if operated on time offered twice and I
simply don't resign that it doesn't
doesn't feel right to me um ok so I've
got a pretty good winning streak you
actually we're not playing well but I'm
winning ok so let's see I'm I didn't
really see that many question the
scandinavian defense for a beginner
player hmm i would rather advice to play
a 45 but the scandinavian has one
definite advantage um it is relatively
easy to play if you if you have an idea
what to do I'll get someone can can tell
you some some things it's kind of ok so
the question how old were you when you
first started playing you mean me
probably um I learn chess pretty early
but I only played a comic book yeah come
competitively let's say with 2 12 13
years old ok I'm playing in mortal am in
mortal I'm going before that is i'm
playing something something funny but
not the bomb cloud
the line i'm playing is actually better
than it looks which is probably not a
big deal because it looks like nonsense
but it is it is not that bad no I was
immediately attacking my F for porn very
evil mr. in water I really wonder what
inmortal what that means did he really
want to say immortal like he's not
mortal or you see in mortal could be a
place um that is actually a very good
move Bishop g2 glass Knight takes f form
okay I have a bad feeling about all this
a queen age for Queen f2 i think is kind
of okay oh my goodness what the heck are
you doing here mr. inmortal are you
kidding me what the bleep so what do I
do now I mean I can sacrifice the sea
three Pawn somehow and i can go Queen d2
let's just go quickly to and ask him
what it is now there's the Queen hanging
and if you move it he gives me the
bishop so not quite clear
so we got we got weird openings aha
gimme gimme gimme so I'm actually a
piece up with this nonsense and I'm
getting quick development what the heck
and I get Bishop e3 and probably you
cannot Castle that's a disaster from
like wow that opening claimed the victim
okay here we go and now it goes castling
beep beep beep you cannot castle you
cannot castle yeah okay um I don't want
to make more fun of him um let's go
there now I'm not saying about songs I
won't I absolutely promise I won't gimme
gimme gimme
what the heck okay I'm going back here
is he going for long castles I guess he
is huh I could also casts a long that
looks kind of funky but I cannot it's
against the rules I can check off course
and just grab everything okay slightly
tricky you can take on f4 it could be
kind of still crazy okay so i think i'll
go here I don't think he has anything at
all I mean it's just he's just lots of
material down okay so what now what is
he going for rookie aid probably
something like that
let's do this so that I can move the
Queen and maybe have not be five
available those this place looks very
very decent and maybe 94 now
might be five rupee five red it's not
really going to work for him but I think
this is better or not at the Texas night
that's probably useful yeah night b5 he
had rookie five I wasn't really sure
about it and this looks cleaner night
Hanks and I might have Quincy three know
where I've got to Queenie three then
Luke c4 is also move Roxy for Queen back
Quincy one that's actually kind of nice
or is that crap right now it looks okay
if it takes a two I can think about rook
takes is six that's actually very close
look see 60 X screen takes Roxy six
takes Queen takes King d8 check on a
eight Kingda 79 f six check and that's
it okay
that's a crazy position but it's funny
I actually overlooked Bishop see Aiden
that line takes Queen takes King dat
niet check he's got okay didn't do it
okay is he doing anything here I don't
see it I can take here right I just eyes
got night g to check Bishop takes Queen
e to mate I have to make sure that I
nite nite g to check Bishop g2 Queenie
to mate this is actually cool wow what
the heck let's cover this nonsense
amazing amazing stuff
okay so put into d5 Knight f6 there's no
maid unfortunately somehow I can this
that should be enough and i only have 40
something second so should speed up
I don't see a win isn't that crazy
at one time mm-hmm oh my god I was that
was that that was kind of shaky but it i
think it wasn't funny again oh my god um
who okay um what does that make the
session I'm scoring like a madman you're
right yeah I won all games that is crazy
ok let's do a next to next one I
actually have a winning position at the
end which is kind of funny oh that's a
pre moving no again I was so kind of
crazy I'm having a five minute request
out don't get a game playing West Farley
are you requested crazy opening smooth
I'm not sure I can do it oh wow
now I cannot even do something very
aggressive against the scanner setup it
is super solid just going to develop
yeah I think this is a this is looking
okay fairly sound solid position the
question do you practice your chest
moves before playing anybody whether in
person or computer yeah of course I mean
I prepare for my games that's a
necessity if you have good opposition
the favor blitz video of mine not quite
sure maybe against will you again see
Carol it was just too great I mean that
I play maybe I don't blame at all I is
very rarely online playing and then I
get this game and he has a really bad
day and I gotta win Ian that was cool I
mean I mean he beats me from 50 games he
probably beats me like 47 times or so
but it just was that that one game where
everything was kind of clicking so great
stuff oh he went to eat too I was only
thinking the other square that makes
deformity dicey move and completely
unnecessary as well Wow yeah anyway
maybe I can make it work at least it
took him a moment till that till it
kicked in the head played this stuff
ready for was a stupid pre-move I was
only somehow thinking of 92 here that
doesn't work at all you can take it
without any compensation and yes I let's
say there's no serious compensation
you
it's so kind of interesting and I was
quick about it I mean it's probably not
really good but it is interesting night
age for now is the idea it's something
that he has to attend to a think
yeah also found it we are dead like I'm
where I was so upset about the loss I
mean I know he wasn't really upset I
guess but it that that kind of behavior
always reminds me of a quote from that
movie from dusk till dawn irwin how they
can tell explains her to to george
george clooney's character are you such
a loser that you don't even see when you
are one and this is kind of the thing I
mean he's one of the best players in the
world and just I mean it's completely
useless to ya to complain or whatever if
you're in such a great position as years
um I mean you should just be able to
just lose the game especially if you
just play badly it wasn't like a lucky
win from you anything night h4 is not
quite working unfortunately
look for is not threatening anything
nothing believe it just made to look
scary I mean 9h for might be might be a
threat but he can go Knight c3 there is
no reason not to do that I think he
takes a long while here mr. Westphalia
no I don't know who my opponent is Sam i
don't i'm not aware go into a five huh
that's interesting move my knight on h5
is just hanging
well that's a pretty bad position
his time will be an issue indefinitely
no night at five is a good move hmm oh
wow
well that's a terribly bad position
um yeah okay Wow
hmm why did he do that it wasn't exactly
necessary okay I mean it's good for him
but he could have played many simpler
things Luke see one no would have been a
good move I believe
yeah I have good chances on time I'm
going to offer me draw here after that
crappy game winning on time feels bad
yeah he agreed to a draw so I could see
it considered one draw here at the end
of the of the stream okay guys I hope
you enjoyed the stream and yeah please
make sure to check my channel tomorrow
for for the final-round coverage of the
London chess classic was a very good
session just considered one draw this
fire says they're pointless my stuff
which means very friendly master there's
a likelihood that I might know him okay
so thanks a lot and make sure to check
my channel and also be online by the way
on Saturday evening for Samuel yeah Meg
also showed you to check that thanks
guys bye